good morning John let me tell you a
little story this morning I was sitting
in bed reading a book with my wife it's
been a little hot here in Missoula so my
windows were open and then suddenly
seemingly from multiple directions
simultaneous screams erupted from my
neighborhood so I roll over and I grab
my Droid because of course if anything
in the world went wrong that droid will
tell me and so I checked Twitter because
Twitter knows the news before the news
knows the news and of course all the
tweets I see are hashtag
oh this is very exciting and John the
footage I just I just showed you was up
from your cell phone camera and at the
end there you can hear yourself saying
definitely two images because apparently
you broke your glasses my guess is that
your glasses are not the only glasses
that were broken because the United
States is moving on to the next round of
the World Cup which makes things even
more exciting for people who care at all
sorry about not really caring I know
that that's kind of psychologically
troublesome for you to have a brother
who doesn't care about the World Cup but
it does surprise surprise bring up
something that I wanted to talk about
there's another wonderful wind that
showed up today YouTube's won its
lawsuit against Franken go see that's
what I would break my glasses why didn't
they have that on the big screen down at
the pub I would have gone to watch that
John it brings to mind the conversation
that we've been having about the fact
that we all lose eventually we're all
playing games and there's nothing that
we can do to ultimately win the World
Cup and the game of soccer in general of
course is an excellent example of this
because that's what soccer is when
you're watching soccer it's all false
hope and watching and watching what do
you want know but then there is that one
goal that happens in a 91st minute in
stoppage time that one time with all the
exertion and the exhaustion and the
frustration pays off and then you get to
scream and dud and make this gesture I
don't know why people do this and it's
wonderful because winning is wonderful
and it's more wonderful if it hurts on
the way there
and I think people sometimes really
don't understand that that fun isn't fun
unless you have unfun stuff to compare
it with people talk about that but it's
hard to actually believe it what would
you really think about success is that
the act of succeeding is the success but
really really what winning is is the
culmination of a ton of hard work and
frustration if you don't have the hard
work and frustration there's nothing
there that's the stuff that gives
winning value and the more important and
the harder thought the win is makes
winning even better which is why it
feels so good about what's happening
with YouTube and its freedom from the
Viacom lawsuit and its
why ultimately I actually feel good
about the fact that the United States
gets to go to the next round because
while I know that we're not gonna win
the World Cup and that we're just going
to be frustrated and angry and
disappointed in the end all that stuff
all that frustration is part of being a
really successful and ultimately happy
person I don't know why that is I wish
we didn't need that stuff but we do a
final note as a colossal win I feel for
me and for nerdfighteria and for YouTube
is the fact that VidCon is like 50
tickets away from selling out so if you
want to get your tickets for VidCon you
got to do that now because we're almost
done here so that's exciting and holy
crap John I will see you on the next day
that we do this Friday